excellent 6 ladies and gentlemen may
taken in the studio to take your site the
opening ceremony and the baltes where begin
thank you
excellences ladies and gentlemen the
opening ceremony will
begin soon thank you for taking your place
excellent 6 the elysée gentleman very good
in the final and for  his honor n pleasure
to welcome you yeah and europe ford 6
european union african union sound
excellences ladies and gentlemen
hello it is a pleasure to
welcome you here in brussels for the
sixth european union summit african union
many of you have done the
moving
we thank you very much
see gray joe ellis to be together again
a deadbeat cartoon live this but
you have you always yes in water unique to
enthusiasts title of
deep is your eyes or partnership now
would have fun radio a eu lie to
highlight the president of pink and the
official and greeting ceremony on
Saturday so I invite the president of
the European council to open the ceremony  deny
the excellences mr charles michel
and i invite you to this desk si
mr michel
ladies and gentlemen heads of state
and
government ladies and gentlemen
each in your titles and qualities
dear friends ex rn6 the index gentleman
of air france
welcome  to blow are strong of sixte
european african union union summit
europe youphil welcome girl in spirit
of teranga fiber detail 1.8 times ait
revolt or africa I hope you
feel welcome in this spirit of spie
quality so dear to the heart of africa
yes
mike good friend macky sall and we both
commission we worked esteem toupin 10 he
wears a particle show a bond
thank you to you made yamaki for you
with the french born a
furious tactic thanks to you my dear husband
special thanks to emmanuel macron 22
times  un shooting presidency emmanuel
your lynch et bien virginie à newport le
dachshund angie have been par crowd en jean
ferniot also to defend your ideas to
make some of humani  ty times fearing
europe on in africa a whole honor for
him to be
taken by a door a policy
itself min we say this meeting fbi impo
all milestone in from europe all the
semites she handles hadas f on the spot a
push all in  and pink as we think i'll
partnership 1 to create new paradise mo
ibrahim fall sting and young africans
foundation f cooked the victims speak
crowd catalyst for new eyes dsn first
think project i also want to salute
louise mushikiwabo my excellent friend
and my accomplice with whom  we
inspire each other on this
relationship between europe and africa
for so many years
of success this collective project is about
much more day 'n' institutionalization
it depends increase in the hand strength of
personal thaïs
european africa yes in the network of
women  and men and men in spite bail de
port of canine project ladies and
gentlemen dear friends the pandemic has been
a test for all of us for our
citizens for our societies it has challenged us
opened our eyes revealing strengths and
weaknesses revealing successes and failures and
that you are European too we hear
well the messages that are
addressed to us and from which we must learn
lessons learn lessons and what you
have done African Union by launching for
example there  less than a year old your
partnership for the manufacture of
African vaccines intended to reduce
pharmaceutical dependence on the African continent within ten years
one against a project that you designed
a project designed by Africans
for Africans and your initiative we
provides an opportunity for us Europeans to
put into practice a new way
of working
a new way of cooperating with
you the european union with our member
states have rapidly
mobilized funds technological
and regulatory capacities today as
I stand  finds in front of you
vaccine production capacities are set
up in senegal in south africa
or for example in  u rwanda ladies and
gentlemen dear friends this summit this
meeting should be we hope
the stage to seal the renewal
of our strategic relationship
we are not here to do
business as usual we are not here
to do business as usual  we
share a geography we
share the same languages
ersonal human ties econo
ic ties cultural ties and we share
a history also with succe
ses but also with its share of pain
history that has not been exper
enced in the same way on both sides  and
on the other side of the
Mediterranean happening we cannot change it
we must know it with lucidity we
must recognize it we must learn the
lessons from it in order to be able to write with four
hands the pages of a more solid
and more robust
future  it is in this spirit that European leaders
stand before you
today we see the
African continent as a dynamic continent
a player in the 21st century parte
natural and privileged areas of europe and
we are gathered here to try
to draw together a common area of
rity stability security we wi
h together to develop the found
ng principles of this pact renew
mutual respect share
interests as equals and this suppo
es  to agree on these fundamental values
y of every human being freedom solid
rity governance because renew
ng this partnership also means commi
ting ourselves to the principles of trust
and trust presupposes trans
arency respo
sibility efficiency that is what  we owe to
our respective populations
it is a daily challenge where we must
and can learn from each other
we see the need for a
stable africa safe prosperous
for africans for europeans
also there is no stable world nor
of europe out of 100 a stable safe
and prosperous africa
affirming this is also drawing inspiration from
the spirit of bundhoo that desmond t  ootoo
explained so well and that we
Europeans are beginning to understand
we are all linked to each
other by invisible bonds that
make us belong to something
greater than each of us your well-being
determines my well-being my well-being  -being
does one determine well-being the prosperity
of africa is in the interest
of europe the financing of the economies and
therefore a priority for us and that is
why we initially launched a
meeting in paris  a few months ago
this project of partial re-leasing
of special drawing rights we
are also, as you know, in the process of
putting in place with the
development banks new and
different innovative mechanisms to finance
projects and risk coverage
with each time a  common objective is
paramount which aims to activate
leverage more effectively channel
private money from a well-chosen
well-identified effective investment projects
prospers  é stabilities
also occur in a space that takes
into account the demographic reality and
on this subject we also face
a challenge that is a common challenge half
of the world's population will live at the beginning
of the next century on the African continent
this means that  we both
have a vital interest in
training young people vocational
training training for jobs of the future just as
we have a common interest in
properly managing the mobility of people
within the African continent of
course as well as towards Europe  by fighting
together against trafficking
and irregular immigration but also by
setting up regular channels
and migration packages
finally
security in africa and europe are
interdependent in 6th grade instabilities
governance defects the costs of
cases can jeopardize
development is engendering risks
for everyone African issues
require African solutions
designed by africans the african union
and regional organizations
play, we know, a key
role in implementing
solutions to the conflict and we europeans
are ready and even determined to
work with you whenever
you wish with a view to an
architecture  more resilient
and better performing security
the who and gentlemen i conclude it is up to us
to imagine and build our future
and we wish to be at your side to
cooperate whenever you express
the wish with optimism with a
new state of mind  dispute with
concrete means we do not want
an announced effect without effect we
want concrete practical discussions
in mutual understanding
and this is exactly the meaning and
round tables that will take place today and
tomorrow whose results
we  hopefully can contribute to
structuring our partnership for
the future we like to say and I like to
say it about our two unions  s that it beats with
one heart and we would like it more
to speak with one voice because
if we join forces our
two continents can make
a decisive contribution to making the world more
stable more just meyer more  resilient
and more sustainable and I conclude if you
allow it with a Togolese proverb which
says and I quote where the heart is located
the feet do not hesitate to go there we
all know here gathered where
our heart is located we are going now
I  hope together to trace the path
to engage us I wish you I wish us
unsuccessful but and I thank you
thank you Mr. President offers us
10 opening world
president senegal chairperson vf can you
nien therefore I ask for your
attention for the president of senegal
the president  in exercise of the
african union an excellent si macky sall
thank you very much
excellence mr president of
the european council dear friends
charles michel
excellence sir  President
Emmanuel Macron
Chairman of the Council of the European Union
Excellencies Ladies and Gentlemen
Heads of State and Government of the
member countries of the European Union and
the African Union
Madam President of the
European Union
Commission  Mr
Chairman of the African Union Commission on
Moussa
Ladies and gentlemen Ministers
Ladies and gentlemen Ambassadors
Ladies and gentlemen Dear friends of the
Europe Africa Foundation Dear friends
on behalf of Africa
I thank you dear European colleagues
for the  kind invitation and friendly welcome
in this mourning and historic
European capitals for our sixth
meeting
after that of abidjan in 2017
we want you
in a spirit of friendship
and loyalty to our partnership
aware of everything that binds us
between europe and africa there is
the mark of the heaviness of history
and a close geographical proximity
by the loan of union to meditate  ranéenne
apem 15 kilometers separate us
between europe and africa
there is human intermingling which has made us
have socio-cultural linguistic affinities
between europe and africa there is the
immense blow of the peace war  together
twice in the space of a generation
in suffering in blood and
in tears
between europe and africa there is finally
an intense and diverse ancient cooperation
this is what binds us
these are the ones that make it special
and the complexity of our
relations as the course of history
accelerates before our eyes,
shaking up
pre-established certainties and habits,
I am thinking, among other things, of the challenges of
peace and security and of
the vulnerabilities that affect us
not only in Africa
I  think of global warming,
of digital opportunities,
but also of these drifts to
illegal migratory flows and the multiple
impacts of an unprecedented health crisis
in the image of the world
more than sixty years after its first steps.  early
independence africa is also
changing africa has changed a
lot has changed
despite some cons performance
the agreement of democracy is gaining
ground in africa over more than a
decade growth it has been
consistently
above the world average
even if it is today hampered by
the effects prove to learn it
mikovits 19
like everywhere else
the african peoples see the world in a
snapshot
they legitimately aspire to well-being
and prosperity
this africa in full mutation
wants partnerships  consensual and
mutually beneficial partnerships
co built on the foundation of
more rites and shared values know civil
zational injunction neither without exclu
ion nor exclusivity with
he other africa wishes to agree on a
edesigned and renovated partnership hero found
you said it  looking for
more than an update of the software
governing the euro-african relational network
we propose to  '
together installing new software adapted to the
changes underway is apt to support
the innovative dynamic that we want to
impart to our relations
together we have agreed to engage in an
interactive dialogue
on a theme
is to reach an action-oriented declaration
in  In this spirit I submit to our
sleep eight proposals as a
contribution to the definition of our
new partner
work together to strengthen
our collaboration in terms of
peace, security and the fight against
terrorism through the
European Peace Facility on the basis of
the experience acquired in
east africa in southern and central africa
the european facility for rabbits
could also support
the efforts of the sahelian countries and members
of the accra process as well as of the g5
that in the face of attacks by terrorist groups
but above all let's work together  to
mobilize the
United Nations Security Council, whose vocation is  t
to ensure peace and security in the
world to invest in the fight
against poverty against terrorism in
africa
second proposal we would like
europe's support to speed up the
process of reallocating
special drawing rights we welcome  the
historic missions of
2,650 billion dollars in the crowd
received its quota of 33 billion to
partly mitigate the shock of the health crisis
it was the first objective
of the may 2021 paris summit on the
financing of african economies
due  of the profound impact of the
health crisis on our
structural economies my wife we call for the r
allocation of 100 billion dolla
s of dts from the rich countries that they conse
t to banks in europe, among other
, in favor of african countries accor
ing of course to  modalities to be agreed
is what will bring us closer
to the target of 2,252 billion
dollars that africa needs by
2025 according to the
international
monetary fund.  ur contain the shock against the cover
and initiate its economic recovery
thirdly
we plead for the relaxation of the
rules of the oscd in
order to better facilitate
the access of our countries to export credits
at conditions of longer maturity
of the rates  more sustainable interest
in also reducing insurance costs
this to strengthen investment
and trade between our two
continents africa I would like to remind you it is 30
million km² 1 billion 300
million people and the needs of
financing of the order of 130 to 170
billion dollars per year according to
estimates the african development bank
for infrastructure alone
we are prepared to work with
our european partners in the
implementation of the global gateway initiative
within the framework  of the program
for infrastructure development in
africa
the pida running
ladies and gentlemen the
structural transformation of the continent pa  sse by the construction
of road,
rail and road infrastructures, port and
airport but also by the construction
of power stations
by gas to power to
provide electricity to 600 million Africans
who do not have
it it is also agribusiness c  is the
industrial and digital platforms
brief in africa construction site that finds its
account in trade investment
this africa there will be able to occupy its
youth
offer its partners
more opportunities for co-construction of
growth and shared prosperity
in the same spirit
explore together the possibilities of
collaboration
around the european project of
broadband connectivity by satellite
in europe in low orbit
i support this european project it is a
project that you can share
with africa because the future of our
partner is to date  also in the
fertile digital field where
the talent of our creative and entrepreneurial youth is expressed.
nante
fourth proposal we wish to
open together with europe for the
revision of the criteria for evaluating the
risk of investment in africa
for africa
the perception of the risk remains always
higher than the real risk
which increases the insurance premiums
penalizes investment
and reduces the competitiveness of our
economies
recent studies show that at least
20% of the rating criteria for our countries
are more a matter of certain subjective factors
of a cultural or
linguistic nature,
therefore unrelated
to risk or  stability of an economy
fifth proposal
we call for the simplification of the
formalities and procedures related to the
conditions of financing of the projects
especially with regard to the global
ghetto rice in the respect of the rules of
good governance and transparency
too often
these formalities and internal procedures  the
formulation and execution of projects
, which weakens public action  and
raises expectations sometimes disappointed 6 let's
act together to
bitter access to the vaccine
is the strengthening of
African pharmaceutical capacities
to the test of the pandemic as u
19 europe has shown solidarity
with africa through substantial donations of
vaccine in  within the framework of the
kovacs initiative and a bilateral title i
express our gratitude and our
thanks to our european partners
but africa is also engaged
in the production of anti covit vaccines in
particular with a certain number of countries
such as south africa
algeria egypt
morocco others like senegal rwanda
ghana and two others are
actively preparing for this
we invite europe to support this
new impetus for the strengthening of our
pharmaceutical and biotechnological capacities
beyond the response  antibodies but
septe let's
combine our efforts for
climate protection and climate justice
support africa first
supports the paris climate agreement
number of  our countries are
developing initiatives for the protection
and restoration
of biodiversity in the framework of
the continental project of the great wall
vac
for a continent lagging behind in the
development process, of
which more than 600 million inhabitants
still live in the
most used obscurity for African name
clearly it is universal access
to electricity and the industrialization of the
continent
on this point we expect a lot from
this summit you said false step of
language of wood but on the great
expectations  from africa we are
waiting for you on the energy issue
on the energy transition I
tell you 600 billion Africans without
electricity continent
needs electricity the continent needs to
develop these natural resources while
waiting for europe solidarity on this
very specific point that is why we
are in favor of maintaining the financing
of the gas industry and for
hydrocarbons for an
energy transition  fair and equitable energy taking into
account the specific needs
and constraints of the continent
8 la frit call for the repatriation of its
heritage
the restitution of African works
remains a high priority for us
because they are part of our
civilizational identity
if we want to build a new
ethic  Europe/Africa relationship
based on respect and
recognition of historical truth
we need to reinforce the work already
started in line with the recommendations
of the savoir 5 report
my dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen
with its proposals the flute addressed
to europe a message  conciliant
is confident in the united destiny
of humanity
our African compatriot this is not
to go sheikh hamidou kane
recalled butter this united destiny in
the ambiguous adventure his
successful autobiographical novel published 61 years ago
the author and relates the  meeting
between africa and the west through
the eventful journey of the young sa  mba
diallo hero of the novel
enter his african tradition
initiated into the arabo-islamic civilization
by the coranic school and western culture
until post university training
samba diallo will finally become a
hybrid character
a child of the world
symbiosis of three
sosa civilizations  he who merges with that of the world
will have to reside in human fraternity
through the dialogue of cultures and
civilizations
which is reflected in a
metaphysical exchange is rather convivial between
the father of 100 me diallo man twice
and for the cross follower of science
c  is Africa and the West that happens
every hour that passes
says the man of faith
brings a complement of initiation to the
crucible where the world merges
we did not have the same past you
and no but we will have the  same future
rigorously
the air singular destiny is over because
no one can any longer live
on self-preservation alone end of quote
62nd after these first
words  onitory challenges us at a time
of complementarities and
interdependencies we all
need each other
, that is to say that fraud cannot be
satisfied with the promise of containers
of the future
according to the fashionable expression
africa has enough  bearing the weight
of history
finally intends to free itself from its burden in order
to be accepted and respected as
part of the new dynamics
that govern global governance and
force the common destiny of humanity
it is the spirit that drives us as we come
to this summit in brussels
confident that between long-
standing partners we can work together
to achieve our common goals thank you
for your attention
thank you sir after the
head of state of senegal
please now welcome the president of
the french republic and current president
of the council of the european union
france presents itself as
an
excellent if president emmanuel macron
thank you b  Mr President of
the European Council Mr President
of the African Union Madam
President of the European Commission
Mr President the
Standing Committee of the African Union
Ladies and Gentlemen Heads of State
and Government Madam President
of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen the presidents
president of the ecb the
world bank the imf the msc madam
secretary general of the oif
ladies and gentlemen the directors and
general managers of
regional development banks ladies and
gentlemen parliamentarians ladies and
gentlemen the ministers ladies and
gentlemen
ambassadors dear friends
everything has been said by the two presidents
so i will try to go as
quickly as possible but we meet again four
years
after abidjan
land of ivorian hospitality and i
salute alassane ouattara for the welcome
that had given us  so reserved and i
thank charles michel for
allowing us  this reunion
between europe and africa at a time when
we are facing multiple challenges
and you have both been reminding us of this
for four years we have,
I believe, together
transformed things a lot by setting up  a
very proactive agenda and the education
of young girls priorities of the
global partnership for education
bring with president macky
sall transformations of the g5 that of the
libyan crisis to the great
green wall to the top of the oceans a
few days ago in  brest we have been able to
identify a euro-african axis to make
prevail a common vision of our
destiny and never sink into
national selfishness we have multiplied
the fields of investment
security peace
economic opportunities education
the judgment I subscribe  completely
about the restitutions raised by
president macky sall for a moment the sport
and then we have been together
facing this pandemic that has
turned all our calendars upside down and I also
want to thank the role that
then president moussa faki and
president ramaphosa played I
remember this session of the office
where basically the acta initiative was
truly co-constructed and that
then we  have focused in Africa
and Europe to build a
common response and convince our
g20 partners to move forward together
so basically Africa is facing challenges
that we know and that we
share for a good part
with but they are even more  great if
I may say on the side of the
African continent the technological digital transition
that of the connection the
climate transition
with if I may say an even greater challenge
for the African continent is
that we must build as has been very well
recalled  President, for a moment, we have to
build fundamental infrastructure
by responding to constraints that our
economy did not have in Europe when
we built an independent society  industrial
therefore it is even more difficult to 10
process therefore climate transition which
is both an energy
and industrial transition the political transition
and the evolution of several regions with
an ongoing process and the
role played today by the
regional organizations
at the
development and investment bank which
I salute here and the african union
and a demographic transition
which is the exact opposite of
what europe is experiencing since your continent
is the youngest in the world with an
extraordinary opportunity but  a
terrible challenge if we do not know how to
help you offer training and
opportunities to the youth of Africa
where the European continent has to live
rather the transition of the aging
of its population which is a challenge if
I may say twins
faced with these challenges
for several years, you have in
addition to crises that have collided with
that of terrorism and
destabilization that our c  the continent has
also known in its flesh but which are
multiplying with international groups
al qaeda is already which have decided to
progress in africa with in all the
region of the sahel of the gulf of guinea of the horn
f africa now we know it well
oo  of southern africa
the advance of terrorist groups which sometimes have
diverse international connections but which progress and
which thrive on misery and which
thrive on the difficulty of providing
opportunities
and the second great shock you have
had in  suffer before like us it is that
of vacuum but I said it and a
few days it is even more
difficult to absorb for the
African continent because it is
a health shock but it is also an
economic and social shock on
more fragile economies in the process of development
and for which the closure is even more
costly and which have budgets which
do not have the same capacity to absorb
these times of crisis
the institutions  s
present here have quantified the
financing needs between 250 and 300
billion euros between 21 and 25, which shows us
the financing needs in addition to the
trajectories that pre-existed, all of this
means that the summit we are holding
today
I  believe is being held at an absolutely exceptional moment,
that of knowing
whether we Europeans are building a
new alliance, that is to say a
totally unique and singular strategy
to help Africa succeed or not
, being aware that success can
not be common  and that sylvia a failure
of the African continent the first to
suffer will be the European continent
and therefore we have no
choice but to build this alliance is
this new axis with several elements
the first is to do together and
not to  to do for and therefore as we
started on several projects is to
build common solutions and in the
method to deeply
review what we are on  next we want to move forward
is to have a roadmap
that reflects this ambition with
concrete projects and this summit will
lead to a text
political declaration and list of projects I think
that the president of the committee will
come back to this and I  thanks the mobilization
of all the services but at least
150 billion euros of investments
over seven years and very concrete projects
which will also make it possible to
reinvent the relationship to build
projects between tallinn is named between
athens and kigali between bucharest  and
abidjan with real uniqueness
and finally on the seven round tables that
we are going to hold
concrete responses to some
of the challenges that president macky sall
raised the first on the financing
of growth where we must keep our
commitments
that of  to meet
the issue of these
special drawing rights but to agree to reallocate
the equivalent of 20% of our special
drawing rights  either by reallocating the
latter and finding the
financial mechanisms so that there is the support
and leverage of African regional banks
or by finding it out of two
the budgetary mode
the second on the climate the
energy transition digital transport
by having  projects on the
sustainable infrastructure that
africa needs it has been recalled there are in
our work I believe several projects
that are in the process of being completed and we
must put the funding and
behind the deadlines the reality of its
projects for the  African youth and
very concrete projects such as the
European constellation which was
presented by the commission a
few days ago, which is a true
north-south project and which, by deploying a
constellation which does not
currently exist for Europe, will  make it possible
to offer connectivity to the entire
African continent
, which is absolutely essential.
If there is no connectivity, it
will not last as long as possible.  ability to deploy
in many areas what we
are doing for ourselves
and real cooperation
third will be on peace
security governance or there we must
complete what we are
doing with salt and the gulf  from
guinea as we announced this
morning but we must also help to
build new solutions
rwanda in conjunction with sadec has been able to
provide an unprecedented response, for example
for the situation in mozambique it is
important that we are there
the financing of such operations
the promotion of its operations and that we
manage to convince the other nations
within the united nations to accompany
this movement
fourth
session on support for the private sector
economic integration we must
as has been said  i think that
president macky sall's proposal is
essential to help reduce the risk of
african economies to develop
projects more quickly but  help
the private sector to invest much more
massively in very concrete projects
there is a youth there is
potential for development we
now need to attract private capital
so that it can be deployed there and can
fertilize and very often emerge from
the informal a lot of projects to
bring them into the formal economy and the dp
and their full deployment
the 5th session will be on
health systems vaccines it was
said by the president we have a
challenge europe is the continent  which has
given the most vaccines to africa which
has helped and
supported europe the most has been the continent which has
now become the first the first
production space while remaining
from the start and even at the height of the
crisis the  more open we have never
put an export ban and we
have always helped more than 50% of the
vaccines produced in europe have either been
donated or exported the challenge is
now production africa
represents  e 20% of the needs and produces one
percent of the doses and therefore we must
do everything to help deploy
autonomy in terms of
additional production and capacities
sixth session on education
vocational training
migrations mobility we will have many
sons  just want to name two to
succeed in these challenges that I mentioned the
African continent needs help
to develop higher
education in vocational training and
apprenticeship, that is to say train its
youth to build the projects that  the
continent has for itself all too
often we have built a
relationship we explain to the youth of
African countries that access to higher
education will be done elsewhere
our duty is to build
very concrete projects allowing this training
and on mobility we must  having
a real alliance of
fair partners which also consists in
fighting together against the networks of
smugglers c
landestines who poke fun at this misery and to
have policies for returning to the
country of origin for those who
do not participate in
protection procedures within the framework of asylum born in
a chosen economic migration and finally
on the  agriculture and sustainable development
we will have to complete
concrete projects such as the
great green wall, which are
essential development projects for
the African continent, all of this is
hollow and we will have to work on it has
completed our work
the basis of an alliance  news and
through its projects and its sessions a
beginning of response
to the challenges and shocks that I mentioned
a moment ago and I consider that
for our generations
it is a responsibility a duty and
an absolutely unprecedented opportunity we
have not  no choice but
to have the energy to carry out its projects to
their end to provide answers to your
interpellations president macky at
the moment you who are president of the
senegal of the african union and which in
addition had added to that the triumph at
the african cup of nations we
will have to have the same vigor as the
lions of teranga to together make
this summit a success and above all to build
this alliance for  our youth I
think it's possible in any case
it's up to us to do it during these two
days thank you very much
thank you thank you Mr President
and his beaches night work of the
president of the european commission the president of the european commission
we  is honored to be with us and
to present his vision of future
relations between europe and africa an
excellent if gentlemen on the ground to van
dalen
michel president
macky sall
president emmanuel macron mr charm to be
noted ionian african moussa faki flo
leader ex rn6 ladies and gentleman
et du very good to be with you
would be
in doing the world we want the leaves
and bust flu grog of the new kind of
cameroonian moussa faki you remember
and  since then we atmani exchange ice
melt with you macky sall a senegalese
president of africa news
on his death in israel
it is a
forward-looking vision
m the prefect is passionate about pulling all
the space how we are going to work
together as we are making of
mastery joy and ruia the tool to
tribal hate solid investments time
job investment i want to talk about
globals gateway
lobby gay
investment in for the
people
the most prestigious
gavanon
richert tigana because we want you chuck
globals gateway interest and around the
world
robert gates webmaster yupps palois
thuan locke
african necsa coming
from cistus not only
strategies now we need you too shall
pass what he needs has
two
priorities des angie
angie
stone the new energy
because we all know first and daxter
economic development in this
we  live in
[Music]
london
are readable in date the ex invest anglo
of gateway projects for example true
blood sugar green eyes of
english origin  e du ska frenchy how to get her
macky sall
said to
transform a
[ __ ] access
people need
electricity
beaten on the weekend but
angie electricity and trust board date
open wide open the door to die african
free trade is nothing
he
has a median  entrepreneurs
or another eni smart business and any
more because we have band and that
fascinating all the sites where
texts extracted internet to develop the
brilliant mariner
africaso sattelite communication
indeed skies bossard continent dring
dring profit
of the respective African student entrepreneurs
of
6 to  develop and marnais manufacturing
capacities at cross africa & dye think we
are making web province then that I himself
well yes this ardennes for as tur
emmanuel is in paris at the top
of here sweden star of hannah we expect to
god  and with two state of fear factory
zenden senegal of the skies the swica and
visitors pastor educated regrets
because besides the be one of the new vaccine
produc  tion side there went straw the
production facilities in
the
wind
power african mining
company
fascinating by
buildings and marl and technology is
phenomenal in the new line vaccine is
ten reversing radars
the
mesh favorite of
tons so vg
into reality
any case of richard  price is now you
have to know we get
cars visit au fort de jake
dennis
lee watar diane generation need to make
their dreams come true
yes to no
16 and few one two go fast
& furious for you get at
the helm like johnnie to get  to someone
is her first milestone ait researcher
vision of two continence working and end
defeated
seventeen i invite the chairman of the
commission of the african union in office
since 2010 is his excellence moussa
faki mahamat
ladies and gentlemen heads of state
and government  on the President of
the European Council,
Madam President of the
European Commission, ladies and gentlemen,
here we are, finally, the time of trial to
overcome reunited physical  ment in Brussels
for the long-awaited holding of the sixth
summit there will be no African European Union there is
no doubt
that the warmth of the reunion will
irrigate with new energy
our beautiful friendship
carved sometimes in pain but
also
in the guts the crucible of l  the history
of geography and of the distinct
developers
also would like to but congratulate the
numerous presence of the leaders of our
two continents and salute the
perfect organization of these meetings
thank you also there for the excellent work
of your teams,
Excellencies, ladies and gentlemen, the
occurrence  de lakovic 19
more than two years already has profoundly
upset certainties
and almost created serious doubts
about the fate of our humanity
its values of solidarity of ge
erosity to see i
the perennial existence of to
ay's universal civilization has r
assured by the
optimistic growth assumptions the fri
then continued thanks to efforts in second
gear combined with  exogenous factors
favorable to
the Landes its upward momentum
within the framework of the
orderly and gradual implementation
of regional integration programs
deeply inspired by Agenda 20
future died out then came
to the surface
the structural weaknesses
of course
lakovic 19 darkened the picture
amplifying fears and disrupting the
circuits and networks of
international exchanges on which the continent
unfortunately remains largely
dependent despite the widespread terror
africa has  revealed an exceptional
resilience
and there to show that behind the
evidence of the fragilities of deprivation
of precariousness of shortages the soul and the
structuring fabrics of the
psychological and mental cultural universe of the
African man provide him with a force of
resurgences like no other
international competitions and rivalries
paten impairments
of a just and inclusive rational governance
have unfortunately opened the
way to all sorts of political and intellectual deviance
the unconstitutional changes of
government which such a situation
makes the beds challenge with unacceptable
arrogance all the
constituent devices of African architecture
standards of democracy and
economic governance
internal savings have led to a drop
of 18%
while remittances
from abroad have fallen by 25% and
foreign direct investments have
fallen by 40
%  against a backdrop of a significant drop
in tax revenue
the scarcity of funding
despite its immense
potential availability reinforces the obsessive question
of economic recovery
the fact that our partnership has not
been able so far to fully succeed in
this mobilization  possible in
favor of a real reconstruction
and modernization plan
and frankly  nt
sorry what is more urgent
which is to take up this immense challenge
to intelligence, to inventiveness, to the
talent for innovation and of course to
our common interests
I try at the start that the knot here
is not  not the availability of
funding but again and again the
gathering of political will
guaranteeing the best allocation
and above all the systems of
fair and united global governance
it is certainly happy to note the
broad consensus on the priorities in
the areas structuring our
common hopes that  they are the
innovative search for financing
connectivity digitalization
infrastructure
climate change energy transition
vaccine production
agriculture and sustainable development
education vocational training
migration and
mobility
economic integration peace
security and  good
governance we now need to go well
beyond the mere  the and simple
incantatory theoretical formulation
often of these relevant priorities
although this declaratory African hero convergence will
surely constitute an
indicator of coherence in a common
strategic vision it nevertheless sins
why these 2 kg by a real discrepancy
between these discursive formulations and their
practical transformative factual fallout
real
if our preparatory deadlines for this
summit have been more diversified better
articulate rejected but if marty charles
for this work it cannot hide
beyond our convergences and the
solidity and solidity of our
consensus on the priorities of the nuances
of the shifts
sensitivities africa is developing a diversity of
partnerships which does not have the same
history
nor perhaps the same scope as that
of our partnership with europe
these new partnerships are no
less relevant is advantageous
for africa is this
and from this point of view are worthy of
respect and taking  taking into account
the hierarchy of priorities is another
aspect where the nuances are expressed in what
place in the pyramid supports for
example the structural transformation
of African economies compared to
that of the values of the models and polit
cal system what
lace to give to training  of
young Africans and their mobility
for knowledge
how to conceal the nuances that
exist on the issues of
ecological transition and
fossil fuels
on the president of the council of the european union
on the president of the european union
of the union  ladies and
gentlemen emerges from the journey so far made
by the partnership there is no
concern african european union
on how the effective
and efficient implementation of the various activities
appearing in the action plans
the readability of the partnership we
can  be reflect who is in
tangible results this concern for how
challenges  our common reflection in this respect
the african union for its part
would like to share its approach on this
important aspect
two parameters could be
taken into account, namely
on the one hand the financing mechanisms
and on the other hand the mechanisms for monitoring
and  evaluation of projects and
programs
the traditional mechanisms have clearly
shown their limits our two unions
are called upon to invent
new ones more flexible more efficient more
productive of results they will
above all have to cooperate
more effectively in the fight against
illicit financial flows and
repatriate funds  resulting from such flows
to africa
the bank practices
periodic and regular variations deserve to be
quickly taken into account because they
offer the benefit of facilitating ricky
economic adjustments
and envisaging the future with
more assurance and control  great
hopes are raised today by
our mouse expectations i  he arouses
within the governments of the elites and
the peoples of two continents are
real
will he be through his innovative
and courageous decisions save himself from a
renewed partnership
revitalize nourishes with a new soul
of pragmatism creator of
concrete structuring and transforming projects
whose hope marked his preparatory work
will he be able to rebuild relations with
africa era whose soliloquies
urge an adaptation to
the dizzying global evolution
where the requirements of the
rationalities of the technicalities of
transparency d re div has cheered up viability
of  equality are the true parameters of
performance and modernity of
governance
the response to this ardent obligation
is the soul of our life wish for the
successes of our sleep and thank you
[Applause]
funk you you're excellence and noah riz
au  point of view ceremony win you
have crime everything concludes denis fichot door
open the top
i have the pleasure declared the so  mmet
open
nadette record lives and i would like to
qualify too
wise shootait which oscillates between origin
this saw your
view
in training and is michael foreman so I
invite you to join your seats in order
to be able to fully enjoy this
show a musical performance which
will have  place on this stage at
take your side with anne we have fun we
dry we have prepared
a surprise for you a musical musical surprise
to start this summit it is an
afro european experience and afro european sauna
experience
in manila or his
mother and  beats all continents tmd front
national they owe musicians a
chinese communist system spats plug in to katia
lherbier more about their philosophy
men we will know where two stars
the american
school life
nineteen and holly canvas scans your
mind is web standards in  ski new world
boss vermin if you can get one music
sound from two country folk you can
dance for ten du front national
accomplices strange  r
in music so music bring pipeau
macha with my life
more experience
[Applause]
[Music]
on
ans
comment
[Music]
bordeaux
drink
[Music]
what
on
[Music]
how
I
[Music]
no
yes
[Music]
to
come young women to chaplin and 20 m
obama plos  ring de saône et loire
old europe
no yes eve à léona to welcome we are
senior really need no
superstar senegalese
football is
an art this gesture
like steve youssou ndour
[Applause]
n this wine
thank you
one who
plays I know you are going to sing for
us  just now where an African
but maybe it's still interesting
to talk a bit about this
initiative I said it
earlier the music united music brienz be nice
I think it's this  initiative of
workshops between musicians from europe
and  africa is a good illustration
that as earlier the
long speeches we said that we can no
longer go alone we have to go
together and this cornsa initiative
and such a beautiful peace initiative that
I  I saw the birth of Ethiopia is
today here and I think it will
continue and it is a good
situation because I told them earlier
they met in twelve
days time  they formed this this
group in fact he didn't even speak the
same language and still that's it
match is right away and the music
is the first language don't
need to speak to each other the sims is the
first  language and
we will see them so we can see that they are
happy they are very quick to do
this and that is really very interesting
these initiatives that I welcome
that I support by the way thank you for being
there you are going to sing for us but
you will first talk to us here
thank
you very much thank you very much ladies and gentlemen the
pr  presidents
heads of state and heads of delegations
dear participant is invited to sell
his qualities
i would like to take this opportunity
to tell you
africa and europe are two old
partners and for this friendship to
continue we must understand now that it is
it's not a question of help
but of a winning partnership for you
and winning for us
the new and very young fiq
very dynamic open and demanding
that's why I'm campaigning for a
young job training
believe me
if  all young Africans know
how to do it
no one will try to
leave africa
I am campaigning for more investment
in the creative industries I am
also campaigning for
the initialization of our continent
with great respect for human dignity
and the environment  this can
not be achieved without the development
of infrastructures to facilitate the
mobility of people goods and
services finally i urge you to
build worlds of where  common opportunities
for africa and for europe by this
level africa
[Applause]
we
[Music]
manaudou
oh
many say that we must pray
and
without borders
the
tickets
[Music]
and that's
it  everything we have only to
make ourselves scream
video
and fatigue there is as they
say everything about us by the troop of the sun
benzaghou bible
of the bunker
[Music]
yes a little
jdo
[Music]
iata
nothing  less
[Music]
hu
m
[Music]
pictures of hateful people 3
fir
this man
I
he m
Thursday
[Music]
who knows
djoudi
who found their
[Applause]
[Music]
yarmulke monkey
dear
[Music]
kwame course
what  lives like
nelson fontaine
holy bible
[Music]
so much
more often
and you baguette
5 you
thank you youssou ndoye thank you to
admit that should be used for music died
of course in-port race in the next or
not of the yates movement  because of course
we want to take h  er family pictures un
guy novés favorite but i lift
all they were to say we were this
black weekend at come together des we
started preparing
bomisso m you can would have said recchi to
masks except and baby boom bap york
hikma soy sauce roundup
ready
2 go
s
as
for the
parts at 8 am towards nice just go
to one and smile
no
the posters at the doors there is a
green stage like a car was turning in togo
at the delirium
meeting high road like to thank you
win folio presents this race a
trio of intention  thank you for your presence
and your attention she has wish you
very successful 100 m thank you very
much